if you had a chance to peer into the
future and see what gaming would be like
in 10 years how could you refuse will
there be a USB six-point out port
funneling VR experiences in ear ear hole
well probably not exactly but virtual
reality will definitely be a part of
your future gaming experiences even
those who aren't excited about the
future of VR have to acknowledge the
groundbreaking implications of the
technology even now in its infancy VR is
being used to treat PTSD to teach
aspiring surgeons to create new forms of
art and expression and obviously for
playing games and after having some very
nauseous experiences with the latency
and low resolution of the earlier oculus
rift models I was excited but hesitant
when the newly-minted devkit to arrived
at our offices but I took it upon myself
to see how the device has been
progressing and I can say without a
doubt that I'm extremely optimistic
after my time with the peripheral of all
the experiences you can currently have
with the oculus rift perhaps the most
impressive and functional is elite
dangerous and it's not just that the
game is markedly more fun and immersive
with the rift strapped to my face my
time with elite and the oculus rift
really demonstrated to me why VR
headsets will be a mainstay in the
future of gaming due to the clunky
relationship between character movement
and head movement in most VR games
cockpit centric games are ideal for the
rig because the player is seated for the
duration of the experience mirroring
their avatar in the cockpit this
obstacle to immersion is removed this
may not sound as important as it feels
but when I ship speeds by your cockpit
you can follow it simply by looking as
you would in real life the immersion
becomes next level no longer you solely
using your radar to follow foes though
the radar is incredibly intuitive in 3d
instead I found myself craning my neck
up left and right in an attempt to
reorient myself and rejoin the fray or
plot my approach you viscerally feel
your presence inside of a ship but its
own spatial dimensions and beyond that
you feel your ships presence in a vast
three-dimensional space where foes can
be virtually anywhere around you and not
just in an off the screen sort of way
but in a way that really feels real and
this can be taken even further as
evidenced in a Valkyrie where missile
lock is established by maintaining line
of sight with your VR headset further
reifying the sense of space around you
in space is the name of the game here
the way that docking and elite feels is
something completely otherworldly it's
absolutely surreal drifting through the
porthole of a massive space station and
beholding the grandeur of its interior
I never once thought this is pretty
immersive as if you are tends to make me
think without a screen border to limit
my view of the environment cavernous
spaces actually felt cavernous a 16 mile
wide space station actually looks to be
16 miles wide the mastoid belt seems to
stretch on into infinity beyond the core
gameplay impact of virtual reality there
are more subtle touches that bring elite
dangerous to life hologram menus float
in the air on either side of you trigger
to action by a mere glance in their
direction your avatars arm pushes and
pulls the thruster and direct response
to your own thruster your position
shifts in the cockpit based on
gravitational forces you hit the boost
trails of afterburner smoke hang in the
air as your enemies try to evade your
crosshairs there are however a few
things standing in the way of the oculus
rift becoming the perfect VR peripheral
the resolution remains a bit too low
though the devkit too is a huge
improvement but there is still a visual
screen door sort of affect one other
ships get far enough away they're
practically invisible except as a few
light pixels set against the black of
space when your position gets out of
sync with where you started you often
find yourself looking down your own neck
hole further there's a degree of
nauseating screen jitter that occurs
especially with the more technically
demanding games but these are the
growing pains of VRS infancy they're
definitely hindrances but the promise of
the medium is still there and while the
current state of the rift may be more of
a proof of concept fit only for the
developers the early adopters and the
thick wallet among us the dev kit too is
enough of an improvement over the first
model in my opinion to have me psyched
for the ever-improving VR experience
especially with games like alien
isolation a Valkyrie to forest and more
on the way with this technology in mind
whether you buy into the hype or not the
experience of putting on a VR headset
and forgetting the world around you is
so immersive so incredibly different
than anything I've ever experienced that
it's hard to imagine a future where
virtual reality isn't commonplace and I
for one look forward to it